a new accuser is coming forward in the
high-profile case against billionaire
investor Jeffrey Epstein
Maria farmer says the disgraced
financier sexually assaulted her more
than 20 years ago Epstein has ties to
politicians celebrities and yes royalty
he has faced numerous allegations of
sexual abuse which he denies but he did
serve 13 months in a Florida jail after
pleading guilty to two lesser sex
charges and a Warner shows us the latest
chapter in this unfolding story Anna
good morning good morning Nora Maria
farmers claims against Epstein were
revealed as part of a lawsuit by another
woman Virginia Jeff ray who is suing
Epstein's attorney Alan Dershowitz for
defamation
Jeff ray says Dershowitz sexually
assaulted her while he participated in
Epstein's sex trafficking operation
something Dershowitz vehemently denies
in documents filed in New York federal
court on Tuesday
Maria farmer says she was an artist and
graduate student when she met Jeffrey
Epstein in 1995 the following summer she
says Epstein sexually assaulted her at a
mansion in Ohio where he arranged for
her to work on an art project farmer is
the latest of more than 30 women who
have accused Epstein of sexual abuse in
2007 he struck a secret deal with
federal prosecutors who let him plead
guilty to two lesser sex charges in
state court
he served just 13 months in a County
Jail farmer also makes claims against
Epstein's attorney Alan Dershowitz
saying she witnessed him visit Epstein's
new york city mansion and go upstairs at
the same time there were young girls
under the age of 18 she's a great
example of a very brave person
Sigrid McCauley represents Virginia
Jaffray in her defamation lawsuit
against Josh what's a farmer's claims
she says so she's standing beside
another individual who's abused by
similar a similar group of people to
help her voice be heard and helped
Virginia's voice be heard
jeff ray has claimed Epstein forced her
to have sex with Dershowitz and others
beginning when she was 16 the Miami
Herald spoke with Jeff ray in their
investigation into dozens of allegations
against Epstein you know before you know
it I'm being lent out to politicians and
to academic
and to people that you LT and people
that you just you would never think like
how did you get into that position of
power in the first place Joffrey is now
accusing Dershowitz of falsely claiming
that she made up the allegations against
him in a statement to CBS News
Dershowitz said he's never met you Frey
she is committing perjury he says I
challenge my accuser to repeat her false
accusation in public so I can sue her
for defamation Alan Dershowitz has
goaded invaded this victim for a series
of years seeing horrific things about
her in the press and so he has he has
claimed that she will not stand up for
herself and she is now doing that with
this complaint chief ray is seeking
unspecified damages from Dershowitz
Epstein's attorneys have not responded
to our request for comment a story
continues yeah story cares for sure it's
the latest installment in a very long
going story that's not over yet and a
monstrous tale thank ya